I wanted to ask what's the number one
thing from a couple different people
you've interviewed so number one I gotta
ask he's you know one of the hottest
topics online Andrew Tate talks to me a
little about you know what are some of
the things that you picked up whether on
or off camera from Andrew that maybe a
lot of people don't get to see when they
see the flash or the hype on social
media what was your take on Andrew are
you close to your mom or your dad uh
probably my dad your dad yeah okay but
close to both yeah but closer to your
dad yes okay uh out of 10 things that
you know with your dad okay are there
areas where your dad is a zero and areas
where he's a 10 in areas where he's a 5S
sure yes sir okay I can say the same
thing about my mom my dad been a lot of
different people right
first time I interviewed Samuel gravado
how could you interview that I mean I I
cannot tell you how many emails we got
and how many different families reached
out to us about that interview oh I'm
awesome oh I mean I can't even tell you
how many why are you interviewing this
guy Sammy do you know what he did do you
know the 19 families
a lot of them reached out to us because
of doing that interview okay
so you know Andrew Tate
how can you interview Andrew Tate when
you see him do this this this this that
okay
the hardest thing people have you know
have a hard time with is for us to
isolate different areas of someone's
life meaning
I can isolate and say
this guy went from two years ago nobody
knowing who he is he's the most searched
guy on Google love them or hate him
there's a lot of Envy there's a lot of
jealousy there's a lot of people that
wish they could do what he does it's not
possible he's one of the best
communicators he's one of the best
storytellers he's one of the best most
wittiest guy that comes up with stories
to tell you at the right time for
challenge to push to do all of that to
troll to talk smack to educate to give a
different perspective
he is a Entertainer a philosopher a
troller if you want to call it that and
at the same time you know a dream seller
is who he is okay so you're able to
isolate and say man this is very
impressive what he's done here this is
pretty interesting what he's talking
about in this area calling out the
globalistic government this this that
very different perspective he gave here
about marriage about this about that
okay and he's empowering men to have a
little bit of backbone right now that
men have become a little bit soft a
little bit of pansies yeah some of the
philosophies you probably don't agree
with hey Pat do you agree with the fact
that he said if you want to have a kid
go to South or Central America get three
girls pregnant and come back do you
agree with that let's isolate that one
area and ask me specifically to that
I'll give you my opinion
uh and then hey do you realize what he's
going through first of all I believe in
innocent until proven guilty you know if
he did what he did the Court's got to do
what they got to do do I believe that
some people can't stand what he talks
about and they want to figure out a way
for that to be silenced just a couple
days ago in the UK you know the Prime
Minister has to sit up and answer in the
parliament about Andrew Tate in UK the
fact that a woman is saying we are
working so hard to work back all these
years of progress we made with boys what
progress with young boys you know these
young boys are becoming pansies you call
that progress to get them to be sissies
that's progress to you that's not
progress but to get into that
conversation where they're now fearing
him we have to do a better job but we
need more money or we're giving two
billion dollars to work with the social
media companies to do a better job
yeah so is he making some points that
he's scaring the crap out of some people
yes are there some young boys that are
taking it and saying certain things to
young girls in schools and they're
acting like idiots is that happening I
100 believe it's happening but you know
what's confusing to me nobody criticizes
little nazex coming down and you know
giving a lap dance to the devil that's
cool with you okay hey nobody says
forget about body count cardi B you're
okay with that all right cool that's
your values and rappers hip-hop or
whatever you know Hey listen what's
Tupac's one of his the song that cost
him his life that's one of the top
workout songs for some guys I like him
that's why I your bit you fat mother
what you what song is that hit him up
yeah did you say anything about that you
know goes back to uh kind of like the
song When Bone Thugs-N-Harmony did where
they use that preacher's uh line where
he says we're not against rap we're not
against rappers but we are against those
thugs thugs Thugs and the song was it's
the thuggish ruggish bone it was by Bone
Thugs-N-Harmony beautiful thing that
they use and it took off it was a great
album more murder all this other stuff
but how come we don't talk about those
things how come we don't talk about the
current rap on how they label women and
these music videos by the way I'm not
telling you to do anything to it so I'm
not one that's saying let's eliminate
all these tips let's eliminate all these
CDs that's a limited all the I'm not
telling you that yeah but if you're okay
with that and all of those movies and
cartoons and stuff that you're
trying to groom kids with you worry Tate
what he's saying no so so the challenge
I have is the level of hypocrisy and
contradiction
where if you are presenting your
argument and you're okay with little Nas
X you should be okay with Tate because
he's the complete opposite side if
you're okay with cardi B you should be
okay with Tate if you're okay with all
these things or the part I will respect
if they say we want to ban little Nas X
and we want to band Tate well then you
have a little bit more credibility
credibility not saying it's true not
saying it's the right thing to do but
now you have the right to say fine I can
entertain that idea because you have
some kind of logic behind it but the
current argument that the opposition of
Tate is creating again let's isolate if
he committed crime I'm not in I haven't
spent the most time I've spent with them
is eight hours so I don't know when I
had my experience with Tristan I like
tristam a lot to me I have two sons I
would love to see the Loyalty of my two
sons be the way that these two are and
how much fun they have with each other
they want to be around each other how
many fathers raise boys and they don't
want to be around each other how many
parents race kids and siblings don't
want to be around each other I don't
know what this father taught these two
guys but these two brothers look at each
other like they're like they're
Inseparable the way they defend each
other you're telling me you wouldn't
want your sons to be that close to each
other set the set the other stuff aside
would you want your boys to be that
close to each other I think so so you
know there's a lot of good there's a lot
of things we can isolate that we could
disagree with that they're doing great
no problem I'm willing to entertain a
conversation but stop with the hypocrisy
and the that you're selling to
people and we have to sit there and take
it from you as if you're so much above
ground and you walk on water no you're
full of your argument doesn't carry
weight yeah and what were they like real
quick Andrew Tate and Tristan Tate off
camera compared to on camera from your
perspective what did I say about you
before we got started in the interview I
said I said what to I said I said you're
a great interviewer right I said you
have the ability to ask questions that
you know not a lot of people are good
interviewers you said I was smooth
you're very smart I told your girl
you're very small and I remember the
first time I walked away okay but guess
what so somebody may come back and say
do you know what Omar did when he was 18
years old I don't know what you did at
18 years old I don't know what you did
at 16 years old I I don't know what you
did at 29 years old I have no idea I
don't know what you went through the
last 12 months you know I I don't know
any of that stuff but if someone asks me
for the two and a half hours that I've
spent time with you I can judge you for
those two and a half hours and the way
you've treated me off camera I can judge
you on that because I have the moral
Authority and the experience to say this
is what I think of this guy based on a
two and a half hours I spent with them
right okay
based on
the eight hours or so I spend time with
these guys you know when I was at the
military we were a very tough crowd to
be to be with yeah so so so me not not
just lock room talk our group till today
like I got one of my guys messaged me
the other day he was my sergeant in the
Army he was a guy that you know on the
weekends he would drink 27 beers and
drink would drive back from Nashville
Tennessee and one time we got into a
terrible car accident I got three
Staples in my head and uh you know we
prevented him from getting the DUI and
eventually anyways a bunch of story with
this guy's stolen car he messages me
we're telling stories to each other
right
if you came in our crew
and you had thin skin yeah
you you would have mental issues that
smoked yeah you would get destroyed so
so the so the the soft you know that the
people were very soft they they couldn't
be around our Circle right okay that's
Tate you can't be around they can take
shots at you and then if you can take it
back at them because they understand
that games it's a little bit of that
okay you're you know it's kind of you
can play the game it's like cooking
talking yeah exactly but then you can
take it and you can give it and all that
it's kind of like that kind of a culture
and then look I mean if you want to have
a good time those guys are probably
going to be the guys to party with the
invited us back the next time let's do
something to Romania I'll say listen man
if you want to go you go I'm trying to
stay married here so I'm not going back
to Romania but you know it was It was a
the the kind of a person that I can go
to dinner with and five hours will feel
like five minutes because I love great
conversations I love laughing I love
talking about important things like
politics and finance at the same time
talk debate do all of that and they
seem like the types of people that do
that naturally okay last question on it
and I got asked what was there anything
surprising that stuck out that maybe you
didn't expect about them
um off camera he shared a few things
that he opened up with that obviously I
I will not talk about but he opened up
okay interesting that uh
he's talking about that and and trusting
and opening up and uh it's it's as if
once the camera was off rather than
being more arrogant and more cocky and
posturing more he went the other way
yeah it was more humble it was more like
this way
where you know there's a part of it
that's Showmanship right he's a he's a
showman now you know you can be with
your girl sometimes and amongst
everybody we act like oh babe I love you
we're holding accounts we get in the car
get your hand off me can't believe what
you said so there is that side that we
don't know either I'm not a a guy that's
can give that perspective the only
perspective I can give is when the
camera was off and the show was off he
was even more likable
more human more human is the right word
I would say he was more human when the
camera was off you're like
interesting man you know you were uh
you're uh
yeah you you saw that so we like I like
you even more with the camera off you
know we can all put on a show
um and then the camera's off and like
okay that guy is really interesting okay
cool I like him oh wow what an
yeah off camera so there is that but for
me it went the complete opposite
opposite way yeah no and I would love to
interview them too but I know they're in
some legal trouble right now uh you can
as I want to go to jail and and you know
maybe spend some time there as well and
sit down and see what you can do but
that interview will never be on camera
yeah it'll be in a different place
yeah
foreign